you want to see the resignation i do
want to see the reservation yes you know
you do have someone waiting to be
interviewed in our initiative it is but
i want to see the race but you want to
see the resignation you want your own
student to suffer
instead of getting our last
as well beg him how do you feel about
the fact that your teacher is insisting
on seeing the end of this game
it's fine he does he doesn't know the
results i guess that's why
i love this lady she comes around
immediately trash talks
love it okay that's it that's what we're
talking about cheating on the show
that's it she's off the show no coming
back
that's it off the teeth
off the pizzas
she might be sitting in your chair soon
christian watch out she's trying she's
training for your chair right that's
what her goal is well let's get back to
this position since we've been wasting
our time on it anyway
if she plays rick87 we're all just gonna
scream
please stop
it's over
rook a8 queen oh there is a stale matrix
i'm not giving you
i'm cleaning and i'm trading off that
rook there is a still matrix there's a
rook 87
trade oh here we go all right
christian's got his moment he's happy
now
we're happy it's over and let's get to
begin who has defeated
a former champ your tournament
you're still in the mix
somewhat
you want a couple in a row you're in
third at least tied for third must be
feeling pretty good
yeah it's nice uh of course i could
score a little bit better
i missed a lot of opportunities actually
to win the games i kind of
i'm feeling a little bit frustrated
about that because i couldn't convert a
lot of like good or winning positions
so it's still okay though in this game
yasser was thumping the the table for a
knight b5 sacrifice early on i really
wanted to do that i really liked the
position and then i started to think
like
probably if i go knight b5 then it's
kind of easier to play for her like she
has some moves to make right but if i
don't play it i didn't see what
she could do with the position and she
was so confused that's why i said okay
why would i force stuff just let's
improve the position and at some point i
felt like she's just gonna collapse
so you went the practical route instead
of the sacrificial right i really liked
that position
as well i knew that it must be very good
for me
and it is
but i thought if i'm not going to do
that
i'm still
fine and i'm gonna play knight f3 and e5
okay she gave to exchange the bishops
and then just i'm playing uh
e5 and c6 always
there was a moment in the game however
when you did play the rook takes on e5
which wasn't very good right which the
engines weren't really happy about the
way things had gone right here she
played bishop b6 when she had a rook
ed8 yeah instead
and this i think we both missed this
move and then i after i took it i was
like something is off in this position
maybe that's why i had to go to knight
b5 i really i don't know why i didn't go
actually i really liked the position
especially after e4 i'm putting just e5
and oh yeah huge huge tactical shot with
knight b5 thematic idea played played
before i just
i thought that my position is still very
good maybe
it's not that good as i expected it to
be by the way your coach didn't want you
to do this i think because he was afraid
of what might happen
uh and he just wanted you to play safe
not taking a chance i think knight b5
was objectively much worse than what she
did in the game
much much worse yeah i i checked it up a
little bit i think it was maybe plus
four in one of our breaks
knight b5 was not that easy queen
[Laughter]
[Music]
no i just saw that it's easier for her
to play there and she has
like many moves to mac but if i don't do
it i really didn't see what she could do
with her pieces she needs she needs to
shuffle but i didn't see how she could
shuffle it but here it's easier to
shuffle yes
only plus zero point four even though
five knight goes back
to e8 or i don't remember exactly okay
but this is what you said and the
computer says yeah yeah white's better
but not and i cannot play really like
after e5 rook d5 because
always she's playing b6
and then i cannot take on c5 because the
queen is like protecting the rook oh
the position that you had on board with
after knight b5 yes oops sorry i've just
made another mistake with the mouse it's
not so easy these tricky little wheels
uh what was the other so the key was
that after knight h7 rook d5 yes e1 is
hanging
well first of all rookie one is hanging
so you like i mean i can never do rook
d5 idea because like b6 and she's always
protecting queen
we squint the rook and the rook is
awesome yeah i i don't have any ideas it
was taking on c5 that's why i thought
that it's very tricky and she has like a
lot of moves to make you know that's why
i really didn't want to go to this
patients did pay off an endgame that
looked very difficult but you were able
to break through
it's the only plan and it's enough to
win i guess okay i thought that after h4
i'm just winning
because i saw that knight comes to b2 at
some point and i'm playing with a4
so this is your first u.s championship
and yet you you feel like
you could have won the whole thing maybe
if you played a little bit better
yeah maybe but you know
we have two more rounds so we'll see in
the end you're representing your chess
team i see there
proud mizzou what is the name of the
chess team um
[Laughter]
we also want a national championship
you need a name you can't just be like
tigers mizzou types i mean we are tigers
but we don't have as a team we don't
have any name right there
you cannot name it it's simple beautiful
and strong what beautiful and strong zoo
chest
beautiful armstrong that's just a name
no we got christian come on be creative
come up with a name the fighting tigers
that's uh pretty sure i'm not allowed
by the university to give just you're
making that up you just said
you're making that i don't want to get
myself in trouble with the marketing
department
okay
all right we will leave it there
congratulations good luck the rest of
the rest of the way
very very nice thank you good luck thank
you